uh let's do a little super bowl fill in
the blank we're both home you got home
friday you didn't stay for the game i
wish you had stayed for the game i
stayed for the game got home last night
great to be home but there's still
plenty to talk about from one of the
great super bowls in recent history if
not ever that 10-point comeback in the
fourth quarter a thing of beauty and uh
let's do a little of that fill in the
blank regarding super bowl 54. first
topic the best player not named patrick
mahomes was
oh it's between two people for me all
right um chris jones or nick bosa and
i'm gonna have to go with nick bosa i
think nick bosa was the second best
player on the field i mean when i
watched the film back yesterday mike
it's just amazing how many plays nick
bosa
was around patrick mahomes and made him
feel uncomfortable that's the one thing
that jumped out for me on the film in
general uh where i you know i knew on tv
mahomes was under pressure but then when
i watched the back back the game on the
coaches film you know it was more
pressure than i even gave him credit for
on sunday sitting on my couch but um as
much as i like chris jones i got to go
with nick bosa here
yeah i you know what i don't disagree
with that i would probably go nick boza
i think you know i want to give debo
samuel a little love because they got
away from using him but early in the
game he was almost like a man among boys
type of a thing with him he had the
longest run ever by a running back in
super bowl history
they tried to set it up for him to throw
a pass yeah when they went back to that
same look that they used early in the
opening drive of the game that resulted
in a field goal he decided not to throw
it ran for our first down instead but it
just felt like he was moving at a speed
different from everyone around him and i
i just wish they would have used him
more yeah no i agree listen like if you
know again you know i'm sticking up for
my buddy kyle shanahan with
what he did at the end of this the first
half and what he did on the second and
five when it was 20 to 17. if i was
going to say one thing to my buddy kyle
shannon where i'd go where did this go i
would've gone where did the demo samuel
runs go late in the third quarter in the
fourth quarter because you're right that
was such a big part of their game they
were having a lot of success with it and
that would have been that would be one
thing i would question them on uh just
because of how talented of a player he
is but uh yeah
yeah it's almost a taste some hill type
of a thing where you know we felt after
the playoff game between the vikings and
the saints if they had used hit a little
bit more maybe they win maybe if they
use debo samuel more the 49ers are the
ones who win the game yeah no i thought
you know listen i i hear that you know
he just he he is a running back or he is
a wide receiver in a running backs body
he is special that way he is a weapon
and i would think you know he's got the
type of skill set that i think shanahan
will continue to develop more and more
plays around him to screw over defenses
okay next topic if the 49ers had blanked
they could have stopped the chief's
avalanche of points in the fourth
quarter defensive scheme flexibility
like you know what i that's what i want
to say mike you know the 49ers play that
seattle scheme i said this in the first
hour three ten point fourth quarter
leaves have been lost in the super bowl
history of 54 years of them they've all
been the same defensive scheme
you know hey i'm third and 15
i'd elect us 49ers double tyre kill you
know make them throw a deep pass to ty
to travis kelsey you know 15 plus yard
completions and things like that are not
his nature to me that would have been
something i just wish they would have
been a little bit thinking outside the
box that way take away
one of the go-to players or aspects of
that chief's offense when they were up
by 10 or up by three or whatever it was
they continue just to play what they
play
hey you know my position
on uh how they could have slowed down
the chiefs on slot in the fourth quarter
right keep patrick mahomes as you said
all year long drinking gatorade on the
sidelines chew up the clock chew up the
clock and chew up the clock don't throw
the ball one of the great ironies of the
2019 post season they had gone and i
know they were having trouble running
like they did against the vikings and
packers but there's a point where you
just take your chances you use debo
samuel you mix it up
and chris here's one thing i don't like
about
nfl play calling when you use a play and
it works
why don't you use it again uh yes right
yes like they could have done they could
have done the reverse flip to devos
samuel again they used it twice and it
worked both times one time he ran it one
time he tried to throw it and then ran
instead when that guy is man among boys
just get the ball in his hands and let
him create like patrick mahomes does
yeah so find a way to chew the clock
find a way to keep the homes off the
field that's what they should have done
yeah i i get it i understand it you know
i i understand the thought and
everything uh again i got no problem
with the play call and to your point
question with your asking like why not
run it again you're right coaches fall
into that trap too much like if it ain't
broke don't fix it you know sometimes i
think coaches look at those plays as
like oh gadget plays where okay yeah it
is a little gadgety sure but it's
successful and it has a purpose and you
know in this particular case the chiefs
were all over just the pure running back
run plays that's where they had pretty
good success for the most part of the
night when it was running between the
tackles the chiefs they stood strong it
was the gadget shanahan outside run
plays that had success and uh you know i
get your point there
is there a concern among coaches that if
you go to that well too often and it
blows up you look bad among your peers i
i think a little bit of all of it i
think you know there's risk in those
type of plays too you know oh man we
went to the well one too many times and
the defensive end finally didn't bite
and we lost 10 yards oh jimmy g
and you know the toss was a hair off or
the you know he is a receiver not a
running back and he dropped the toss
whatever it may be i think all those
fears go into coach's heads a little bit
to where they could just go yeah they go
back to the conservative this is what
works i know it works we practice it a
lot let's just do that
okay next topic most questionable call
of the game by the officials was you
know i mean first off i want to say
great job by bill vinovich right all
right early in the game did you see that
you know we have the coin toss bill
vinovich took your advice mike did you
know that
he they the kansas city didn't know how
to answer the defer question you mean
you mean the don't be an idiot advice
exactly what an idiot he just took it
over and he's like yeah you want to kick
the ball right yep you want to kick it
right he finally took charge to where we
were talking about i know early in the
year like yeah come on let's not try to
screw the other team up because they
don't know the the language of the the
like they need to change that all
together anyways it's just stupid if
it's that confusing and guys who played
football their whole life still don't
know what to freaking do like change it
uh but the most questionable call the
game
i have no issues with any of the the the
closest one to me was the damian
williams touchdown you know i i do think
he got in
you know but this is to the point of
mike florio again like i'd like to see
us have a little more advanced
technology with plays like that
yeah so we would know if the if that if
that ball had crossed or at least kissed
the plane before the foot was out of
bounds hey
i think it was only the last week sean
payton was on with us talking about the
the zebra technologies next gen stats
and the things they can do and the stuff
they can put in the ball it was pretty
clear he's in favor of embracing
technology so we know
is the ball across before the foot hits
the white line right and it would have
been it would have been it would have
been like in tennis they know when the
ball hits the line right oh right would
have there's no room for discussion
there's no room for debate the ball is
at or across the front of the goal line
before the foot goes out i think for for
that moment and you've given me an idea
i'm going to write about this this is
this is something we really need to get
into yeah there wasn't enough visual
evidence to overturn it okay well but
maybe it was wrong we just don't know
and if you had that precise technology
you would have known and it is a super
bowl deciding call right because if he's
not in it's fourth down you're going to
kick a field goal you're going to go for
it i mean who knows we'd have to go back
to that point again but it put the
chiefs ahead late and it really allowed
them to win the game and i think it's
all the more reason to have the
technology and to spend nfl you're going
to be making so much money off of
gambling please please it's not about
making as much money as possible except
when the players are trying to get paid
because they haven't made it and they
don't own the teams but for the nfl
spend the money on the technology so we
avoid topics like this i guess it's good
for us right that's what jeff fisher
said once upon a time when he was on the
competition committee and he was and we
were agitating for expanded replay well
it gives you something to talk about
well yeah but i'd rather not talk about
it i'd rather i'd rather that we get the
calls right and we feel that that we can
move on and everyone's confident that
accuracy is being honored and achieved
for me the most questionable call and
i've been hearing a lot about this from
49ers fans you know it's never we
weren't the better team that day right
it's always someone screwed us and you
know no holding penalties the entire day
for the chiefs no offense of holding
when you consider that that uh four
horsemen in the apocalypse they were
trying to contain are you telling me at
no point during the day any of those
guys got held that's a little
questionable for me well yeah i get it i
mean i you know again i think the the
history of the super bowl though
one okay yeah there's normally not as
many penalties called why is that well
it's the best refs for one okay so
they're they're there for a reason they
don't over officiate the game two what's
the other reason well both of these
teams are in the super bowl because
they're good and they don't commit a lot
of penalties so that that that's part of
it as well you know and then i think
three
naturally yes i think we've seen here in
recent history that the refs kind of let
the teams play in the super bowl it's
only going to be egregious penalties
that are going to get caught for the
most part now again i wasn't sitting
there watching every block and
everything like that you know hey you
know do i think they called it a little
looser that way yeah sure i do i do but
i also could point out a few plays and
go oh the 49ers got chris jones hooked
here and that could have been called as
well so i i don't i'm not going to buy
into that um
i'm not going to buy into that if you
want to complain about anything you just
want to say hey why don't we officiate
the super bowl the way we do the rest of
the year you know that's where it's a
little different sometimes and i feel
like in the playoffs it changes it to a
degree all together
and that's part of what good coaches
have to factor into their preparation
because if they're not calling holding
you know what go home push the limit
right that's
take advantage of it it benefits both
teams equally all right couple more
before we break blank was the biggest
thing i was wrong about in this game
well i i i think it's got to be like i i
never would have thought that the chiefs
would dominate the time of possession
and be the one that kind of had kept the
ball
and you know not that they dominated but
they won the time of position but by a
significant amount of time where i
really thought at the very best it would
have been flipped around where like the
49ers would have had the ball for 33
minutes and it would have been the
chiefs at 27. and i was more like man i
hope it's not like the 49ers have the
ball for 40 and the chiefs only have it
for 20. that's really where i thought
the game could go so that was i think
something i didn't look at the run game
andy reed's patience with it i did not
expect that i thought he would use more
of the passing game to help out the run
game screens things like that but he was
patient and andy reid threw us a
curveball and showed us that he is
capable of running the ball in big game
hey you know what i was wrong about i
was wrong about the chiefs winning by
double digits i never would have dreamed
that they would be the team to win big
right i thought they would win but i
thought it would be close it's gonna be
double digits
it was gonna be the 49ers i did not
envision under any set of circumstances
the chief's winning that game by 11
points that's the happiest thing ever
mike i still was in disbelief last night
i came home and a few times last night
with my wife i was just like
i i still can't believe what we saw last
night i mean it was 20.
i got the cough button but the camera
can't cut to me while i'm coughing wrong
cut that's all right that happens hey it
happened
i still have i still have uh yeah that
last little bit of bronchitis aren't you
glad i'm not sitting next to you yes i
am i'm very grateful that you're not
sitting there coughing on me like you
were all last week yes uh all right one
more real quick one it will be blank if
the chiefs aren't the afc representative
in the super bowl next year it will be
blank if the chiefs aren't in next
year's super bowl
which team will it be not it will be
disappointing
which team i did i don't know man no
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm reading it
wrong put in whatever words you want it
will be blank if the chiefs aren't in
the super bowl next year put in whatever
word you want no yeah i'm gonna say uh
it will be
upsetting to me if the chiefs aren't in
the super bowl next year i think they're
set up
i think this is only going to catapult
the kansas city chiefs i just look at
them as one of those team that's going
to feed off this and like i said
yesterday yeah they're they're the
favorite i mean i know baltimore is
dangerous and i know new england ain't
you know going to sleep at night here or
anything like that either
but i just look at this like
i only think this is going to make
kansas city greater andy reid the
pressure's off mahomes you've done it
you're an mvp you've done it all there's
nothing you've overcome the greatest
obstacle you beat the best defense in
football and you were down by 10. to me
like the pressure's off there'll never
be a situation again with the history of
those two together where they're going
to be like we can't overcome this
they're going to be i just think this
catapults them into greatness and i
expect them to be back in the super bowl
next year
yeah i do too i think that the question
is will they win a second one depending
upon the quality of the nfc opponent but
uh all due respect to the ravens and
kansas city will play at baltimore
next year they also play at new orleans
a couple of good road tests for the
chiefs their home schedule the toughest
games are other and who knows look they
they own their division i'm i i don't
want to disrespect the chargers raiders
and broncos but they own that division
they got the patriots and they've got
the uh texans coming to town easy
schedule that they should be right in
the mix for a first round buy if not
home field advantage
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports